thank you  oh damn  can you get in there I screamed man  positive but you could do nobody ain't  nobody respond  right is everybody in there  just going jump  fast  yeah  we're gonna bust this uh  here's going out here you push forward  everybody watch your little heads  thank you  I can see one for sure I don't know  come on come on  [Applause]  come on get out  wake up  break this windshield  come on we gotta move let me know when  you're ready just grab it yeah all right  we got pull him out come on come on get  him get him out of here  I don't see anyone else no one no that's  it that's it  all right let's get him out let's get  him out  walk left  grab this move go I'm good just move you  got him here  come on boys  [Applause]  yeah hey just put them on the ground in  the grass right here